our first look at Miley Cyrus and Woody  Allen in their new Amazon series crisis  and six scenes is here I'm working on an  idea for television series now I see the  usual dysfunctional family with the  wisecracking wife and kids and much  harrass husband kind of thing yeah all  right wow you're beautiful I met Alan  did you  I gave him marijuana six Episode comedy  takes place in the 60s and follows a  suburban family whose lives get turned  upside down by a guest and we might know  who that is  well she doesn't criticize me as he's my  navel oranges I don't dislike you it's  just everything that you stand for it's  double the Miley this fall the show  premieres on September 30th  just days after she makes her debut as a  coach on the voice I'm here to make  people happy and make my I feel flowers  on the inside